je sais pas si vous êtes intéressé par
une maison plus connectés parce qu'il ya
plein d'objets intelligents qui doit
permettre d'optimiser notre intérieur et
dans tous ces objets dans tous ces
objets oui depuis son objectif
mesdames messieurs il y a le ca ça c'est
le nouvel aspirateur actes et de broc
alors je ne suis pas une chaîne qui
parle beaucoup d'un aspirateur c'est pas
le coeur de ma chaîne mais je vous parle
de ce produit et je vous ai déjà parlé
plusieurs fois de provident au robot
rock pourquoi tout simplement parce
qu'ils ont des produits qui marche
extrêmement bien et qui en tout cas pour
moi à la maison le solutionner vraiment
le quotidien et m'enlève une vraie épine
du pied je déteste faire ménage je
déteste faire ménage par dessus tout il
le fait pour moi il le fait bien il l'a
fait de façon intelligente c'est ça
c'est bien et forte aujourd'hui le tout
nouvel aspirateur de robot rock c'est le
s6 max v qui est très cool pourquoi
parce qu'il vient solutionner un
problème que j'avais pas identifié
encore dans les anciens aspirateur robot
rock comme quoi voyait la technologie ne
s'arrête pas et ça nous solutionne des
problèmes qu'on connaissait même pas et
bien c'est que là vous avez une double
caméra c'est une vision stéréoscopique
alors qu'est ce que vient faire cet
aspirateur
eh bien il vient inspiré il vient de
nettoyer votre maison ça c'est un peu
l'idée première mais en plus de ça il
est intelligent il vient reconnaître les
objets il les évite ça évite qu'ils
viennent les pousse et ça évite qu'ils
viennent tout bouger chez vous et il le
fait extrêmement bien mais avant de vous
le présenter que vous invite à venir
vous abonner en cliquant sur le petit
bouton que vous avez là parce que je
vous parle bien évidemment de vous de
votre vie numérique je vous présente
plein de nouveaux objets pour venir
optimiser tous à des smartphones et
tablettes démontrer voyait de temps en
temps certains produits six robes robes
parce qu'ils sont très cool et je vous
parle bien évidemment de vous de votre
vie numérique
est-ce que c'est dangereux dormait à
côté ton smartphone commandes mieux
charger son smartphone est plein
d'astuces étudie donc si ça vous
intéresse avec bien évidemment venir
cliquer juste en dessous vous actionnez
la cloche comme ça vous serez notifié
dès qu une prochaine vidéo arrivera
le bébé alors pour tous ceux et toutes
celles qui seraient pas forcément tout
le sud y ait de la spirra des
aspirateurs robot rock je vous
expliquais très rapidement comment ça
marche là vous avez l'avant ici vous
avez une caméra stéréoscopique ça c'est
là toute nouveauté de ce produit je vous
expliquer comment ça marchait vraiment
vraiment vraiment très très bien il
vient reconnaître vos objets grâce à une
vision stéréoscopique un peu comme aux
yeux avoue ça c'est super vous avez ici
un petit laser tu vas venir cartographie
votre pièce et reconnaître les murs et
lorsqu'ils arrivent contre un objet là
il touche sa rentrant pas intérieur
comme s'attaque qui décale il avance et
il contourne les obstacles
[Musique]
également régler votre caméra
reconnaissance d'objets avec elia oui
voir les photos où il va faire des
photos comme ça vous saurez exactement
ce qu'il est venu éviter ça s'est
vraiment bien et également le détail des
animaux domestiques parce que oui pour
reconnaître si vous avez un petit chien
un petit chat comme ça ils éviteront cdh
su contenir le programme d essais ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure vous
pouvez dire d'un cul démarre par exemple
j'en sais rien moins qu'un 15h37 c'est
parfait par exemple il va venir dans ma
chambre le lundi le mercredi et le
vendredi
a contrario je peux rien je veux qu'il
aille par exemple tous les jours dans la
salle à manger je peux vraiment venir
définir sa et définir également le mode
de nettoyage dont vous pouvez venir
régler votre puissance en fonction de
vos hommes mais également en fonction
des jours de la semaine en disant balles
mardi et ira plus coup le mercredi par
contre tu vas tartine à fond vous pouvez
lui dire va dans telle zone par exemple
je clique l'âge mais aller il y va
directement et vous consultez bien
évidemment historique du nettoyage ça
c'est vraiment cool je vois les endroits
où il est allé il a reconnu
effectivement les chaussures ici il a
reconnu une multiprise des multiprises
un peu de tous les côtés et on voit bien
partout où il est passé il a fait le
tour de la table ici le tour d'un
fauteuil le tour de la table basse
autre opportunité qu'a très cool tu peux
venir piloter mon robot pour de la
surveillance à domicile j'ai qu'appuyer
juste ici et là j'arrive sur cette page
alors hop je me mets en plein écran
il vient se connecter directement à mon
robot qui se met en position et là je
peux venir le déplacer très facilement
pour voir ce qui se passe chez moi je
suis en haute définition sur les
finitions un peu plus basse que le
renvoi il s'en charger je peux les
nettoyer je peux venir parler
directement dans la pièce si je le
souhaite la jeunesse un petit message
qui va diffuser par le robot et ensuite
j'ai l'historique de mes anciens
messages c'est chouette les renvoyer
très facilement et je vois exactement
voyez où il est sur la carte ça me
permet ans que je suis au travail je
suis une importe où et bien de voir ce
qui se passe chez moi très facilement et
vous avez en plus des capteurs sur le de
soupçons des capteurs antichute vous
pouvez le mettre en haut d'un escalier
il ne tombera pas
vous avez des petits boulots pour venir
piloter et vous retrouver ici hop un
endroit où vous ranger tout vous avez
ici votre à bach avec toute votre
poussière qui est là vous ouvrez vous
videz je les fais juste avant c'est
merveilleux ça marche bien de quoi venir
le nettoyer aussi ça s'est très très
bien et vous avez à l'arrière un énorme
bac à eau qui est beaucoup plus grand
que sur les anciennes générations vous
venez ouvrir vous mettez de l'eau est
uniquement de l'eau et en plus de ça
vous avez une petite serpillière vous
allez pouvoir venir changer parce
qu'elles sont interchangeables
ça c'est très bien on a plusieurs qui
sont fournis avec et qui va venir
nettoyer votre sol
[Musique]
et si vous regardez en dessous comment
ça marche eh bien voyez il va avancer il
va aspirer il va tourner il a tout
ramassé est lui aussi va tourner pour
rabattre les cochonneries directement à
l'intérieur c'est donc un produit qui
lave qui nettoie qui intelligent qui
repère et qu'on peut venir commander
grâce à une application qu'on peut
retrouver bien évidemment sur ios mais
également sur android l'application ces
robots rock et grâce à elle vous allez
pouvoir prendre les commandes de cet
appareil les pouvoir faire beaucoup de
choses
elle est très loin je vous montre
comment ça marche la plus rock
je les planqués ici dans mon petit
dossier maison et à se situer juste ici
dans ce tapis j'ai retrouvé mon
aspirateur jeu le sélectionne et là
j'avais sur une petit tableau de bord
qui vient reprendre la maison qui a été
cartographiée ça c'est mon appart
bienvenue à la maison les amis toutes
les zones que vous avez là en plus ce
sont des baies vitrées s'était ouverte
aux qu'avec le laser il est venu un peu
voir ce qui se passait dehors ne guère
plus loin il a jamais différentes pièces
maîtresses de la grande pièce de vie
changent chambre de mon fils j'ai mon
bureau je bosse et là j'ai mon entrée
comme ça vous connaîtrez tous vous avez
visité la maison j'ai fait un petit
nettoyage de zone parce que j'avais une
[ __ ] et qu'ils étaient tombés là
donc on va combien de temps ça dure et
ça a duré cinq minutes a eu six mètres
carrés nettoyer ma batterie est toujours
à 100% alors ici j'ai plusieurs choses
qui sont vraiment bien de venir nettoyer
des pièces je peux dire bien nettoyer ma
chambre viennent nettoyer la chambre
d'elliot plus donné plusieurs pièces à
venir nettoyer et ensuite je clique sur
nettoyer il parie nettoie ça c'est du
nettoyage par pièce je veux faire du
nettoyage par zone peut le dire par
exemple up dans mon entrée comme j'ai
fait l'autre fois bien nettoyer ce
périmètre là parce que c'est là où j'ai
fait tomber une cochonnerie je
sélectionne la zone une fois de plus
appuyé sur nettoyer et il par là bas
donc ça c'est bien mais on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin notamment ici au
niveau de la gestion des cartes je peux
par exemple lui donner des séquences lui
dire tu vas commencer par la pièce de
vie ensuite tu feras le bureau ensuite
tu feras ma chambre la chope d'elliot et
tu finiras par l'entré jeu peut ensuite
venir modifier une pièce par exemple je
peux venir fusionner deux pièces ni aux
places et deux pièces là et bien je veux
qu'elles fonctionnent ensemble je vais
cliquez sur fusionner en dessous alors
je veux dire diviser une pièce si je le
souhaite en disant maintien par exemple
vous voyez ici cette pièce et les
grandes venir la diviser ça c'est le
côté salon donc je dis vi a nommé agent
ma carte
le côté salon l'âge et le côté salle à
manger l'âge et côté cuisine comme ça je
peux venir segmenté ma pièce mais je
peux venir également personnalisé peut
dire par exemple quand tu vas me faire
le salon qui va venir respirer à fond
je veux que tu mets toi vraiment
beaucoup parce qu'un tapis parce qu'à
plus de cochonneries dans cette pièce là
tu me fais ça en termes d'eau tue mais
aussi beaucoup d'eau parce que tu
nettoies vraiment à fond par contre dans
mon bureau où il ya beaucoup moins de
cochonneries seule chose d'équilibré et
tu me mets un petit peu d'eau mais pas
trop parce qu'elle n'a pas
particulièrement besoin
et lorsque tu vas venir faire à la
chambre d'elliot et bien je veux que tu
aspires quand même suffisamment fort
avec le mode turbo et tu restes sur
l'eau moyenne ça m'ira très bien et tu
feras la même chose dans ma chambre
turbo aux moyennes je veux dire
personnalisé l'aspiration et le
nettoyage en fonction des zones dans
lesquelles ils valent et je peux définir
des nougats zone des pièces où il n'ira
pas soit avec des zones interdites je
veux dire par exemple je veux pas que tu
fasses une petite partie de la chambre
d'elliot dans lequel il va avoir son
circuit qui est planqué juste ici donc
là tu n'y vas pas tous n'espèrent pas
comme ça ça évitera qu'ils aient des
problèmes dans la chambre d'elliot et
puis me fera pas la tronche si jamais
l'aspirateur vers les bouger son circuit
parce qu'autant il va reconnaître les
chaussures autant de circuit est
vraiment très très bas à une petite
distance du sol et il n'a pas le
reconnaître comme un objet ou alors je
peux lui dire carrément eh bien je vais
créer un mur invisible et tu ne vas pas
du tout cette fois ci dans la chambre de
mon fils comme ça il ne franchira pas
cette partie là je peux aussi définir
une zone sans lavage en disant écoute tu
viens tout me laver sauf ma chambre par
exemple je veux pas que tu malade je le
ferai moi-même et si je veux plus gk
venir à les supprimer en cliquant là
[Musique]
en suspendant paramétrage de façon un
petit peu globale en lisant déclic moi
je veux par exemple au dessus nous aide
beaucoup de cette fois-ci puis un petit
peu moins la prochaine fois de façon
globale sur l'ensemble du nettoyage est
pareil pour l'inspiration turbo maximum
en sachant que si je mets au match à
venir à peu diminué l'autonomie de mon
repos vous voyez c'est en ça que c'est
intéressant et un sac cet aspirateur
robot vient vraiment optimiser votre
nettoyage intérieur vous faites-vous
paramétrage de base vous définissez vos
hommes vous définissez les séquences la
puissance d'aspiration et vous pouvez
même aller plus loin en définissant des
jours en exemple plus les jours par
exemple qui va passer dans la cuisine et
la salle à manger qui sont des zones qui
pourraient être potentiellement un peu
plus sales mais tu dois passer que tous
les deux jours dans les champs qui sont
des zones un peu plus propre
vous pouvez aller plus loin dans vos
paramètres ici vous allez dans les
paramètres de l'aspirateur vous pouvez
activer le mode moquette ou avoir en
recrue de puissance lorsqu'il va venir
sur votre moquette pour définir un mode
ne pas déranger lui dire de notre
terreur était la personne qu'il va
strictement rien faire et un dernier
portugais même pas mal c'est la partie
entretien je sais dans combien de temps
je vais devoir changer mon filtre ma
brosse latérale ma brosse principal il
me reste 26 heures avoir nettoyé mais
capteurs qu'après il vous indique
comment le faire mais ça ne s'arrête pas
là parce qu'aussi os x qui est vachement
intéressant vous allez dans la gestion
des cartes ici et vous allez pouvoir
paramétrer votre carte
alors ce qui est vraiment bien ici c'est
que voyez par exemple j'ai ma carte qui
s'affiche ici qui enregistre et les
cheveux venir a ajouté une autre carte
ce qui est bien avec ça c'est notamment
pour les maisons ou les appartements
étage
parce que oui vous pouvez venir créer
différentes car je sais pas si vous
habitez en maison ou en appartement
d'ailleurs dit l'émoi en bas en
commentaire c'est c'est un appartement à
plusieurs étages ou si vous avez une
maison avec plusieurs étages premier
marqué on va en commentaire moi j'ai ici
un seul étage il vient donc faire le
tour mon étage mais imaginons que
j'habite une maison ou un appartement
avec un deuxième ou un troisième étage
peu importe est bien et ce pouvoir créer
une deuxième carte de mon deuxième étage
alors je bouge pas ma base elle reste là
où elle est à mon point fixe mais je
crée une deuxième carte de mon autre
étage
je lui faire faire le tour et dormir
tout cartographier banon connaître mon
deuxième étage et créer une pièce est
bien de la même manière il va venir
nettoyer les pièces selon les paramètres
que je l'aurais très définis pour ma
deuxième cadeau pour mon deuxième étage
donc ça c'est vachement bien vous pouvez
aller jusqu'à un maximum de quatre
cartes ce qui vous permet d'optimiser
complètement le nettoyage de votre
maison que vous ayez un étage deux
étages trois étages ou alors même
carrément quatre étages un château à
quatre étages donc ça c'est bien et en
plus de ça votre aspirateur de rebond
quand vous être intelligent d'avoir une
vie
stéréoscopique et bien il voit dans
l'obscurité grâce à l'infrarouge nous
voyons là une solution qui est vraiment
complète pour le nettoyage de votre
maison alors il ya des endroits où il
n'ira pas à sa faim même sous lesquelles
il ne pourra pas passer mais je dirais
que l'avenir dégrossir 90 % de votre
ménage si vous le paramétrer bien si
vous optimisez bien et bien vous verrez
que vous n'avez plus grand chose à faire
ou à venir en complément avec un robot
rock achi ce que je vous ai déjà
présenté et croyez-moi de piger des
aspirateurs robot rock à la maison ça
nous change complètement mon quotidien
j'ai plus qu'à le laisser partir si
obstacle si donc je définis ne nie pas
c'est très très cool dites moi si vous
utilisez un aspirateur robot à la maison
si vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
et qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
petite bête là c'est le robot rock est
sis nax v qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'idée de la vision stéréoscopique sur
ce produit là est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait vous tentez est ce
que vous pourriez prendre pour chez vous
marquez moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire d'ailleurs s'il vous
intéresse je vous ai mis un lien en bas
par la description a vous de me dire
tout ça bien évidemment en bas quand on
se trouve extrêmement rapidement parce
qu'on a plein de te raconter plein de
nouveautés plein de belles surprises et
croyez moi avec très cool sur ce je vous
embrasse
je vous dis à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]